born on the run a new baby arrives to
add to the growing number of Sudan
refugees in Chad the young mother says
she was forced to flee after gunman set
her family home on fire in 10 Delta she
later went into labor with no access to
medical facility or staff
my mother and sister
birth the United Nations says among
thousands of refugees who arrived in
Chad are pregnant women and children
whose conditions remain dire we are
seeing
um
sadly expecting a peak of malnutrition
in a region which is already has very
bad indicators for a childhood
malnutrition Aid agencies have promised
to step up operations but there isn't
much to give conflicts Sy around the
world have used up much funding from
increasingly fatigued donors this could
mean tougher times for thousands of
crossed over into child and thousands
more who are trying to leave Sudan
shortly after the interview by Al
Jazeera address top administrator paid
the newly born and his mother zamzam a
visit
not only the mother but everyone will
soon have access to Medical Care from
our mobile clinic
are lucky in comparison to the majority
of Sudanese refugees in Chad
the not so lucky ones will have to wait
on donors and their Goodwill for now
though not much seems to be coming their
way
Ahmad Idris Al Jazeera